مع جروح الليل قوه اسرائيليه خاصه تحاصر
مبنا سكني على اطراف مخيم جنين سرعان ما
تحول الحصار الى اشتباكات المسلحه عنيفه
[تصفيق]
قتلت القوه المداهمه نعيم الزبيدي ومحمد
السعدي احد قاده كتيبه جنين ومقاتلا في
سرايا القدس التابعه لحركه الجهاد
اضراب الوحدات
وسط مخوف اسرائيليه من رد قد يكون من
الجنوب
وان ردت حركه الجهاد باطلاق الصواريخ من
غزه ردا على عمليات اغتيال في الضفه
لم يكن لنا خيار سوى المواجهه واذا ضمن
العدو اننا سنرفع الرايه البيضاء فهو واهم
واهم واهم وغاشم حاله العرف ده والاستفراد
بالدم الفلسطيني لن لن تنتهي الملعب من
عقدتنا
الجيش الاسرائيلي رفع درجه التاهب في
الضفه الغربيه وفي الجنوب والذي تلونت
سماءه بخطوط بيضاء نتايجه تجارب صاروخيه
تجريها الفصائل في غزه وفي الضفه الغربيه
التي قتل فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي سبعه
فلسطينيين في اليومين المضيعين انتشار
وتجديد على الحواجز خشيه عمليات رد فيما
تواصل السلطه الفلسطينيه شكاها بعدم وجود
شريك اسرائيلي يؤمن بالسلام ويعمل مع
الجهات الرسميه لنزع فتيل للانفجار
في اسرائيل يؤمن بحل الدوله على اساس
الشرعيه الدوليه
والاتفاقات الموقعه ونبذ العنف والارهاب
بذريعه الانذارات الساخنه والقنابل
الموقوته والتخطيط لعمليات تواصل اسرائيل
تصعيدها في الضفه الغربيه مزيدا من
الضحايا ومع كل جنا يشيعها الفلسطينيون
تعلو الاصوات المطالبه بالانتقام لتتحول
لعمليات دهس وطعن وقد تتطور لما تخشاه
اسرائيل من عمليات تفجير وسيارات مفخخه
كما حدث مؤخرا في مدينه القدس عبد الحفيظ
جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه